my name is Catherine cease I'm an
archaeological conservator and I am
presently the conservator at the Peabody
Museum here at Yale this morning we
heard a number of case histories of
problems in the Middle East and
elsewhere and in this session we will
hear some responses that have been
developed by various organizations and i
should say right off that the first on
your program the first presentation
listed for this session we will postpone
it and put it to the end because the
presenter is not here so we will start
with a Corrine Wegener I met her as arts
when she was arts monuments and Archives
officer in Iraq in 2003 she is the
Cultural Heritage Preservation Office at
the Smithsonian Institution in
Washington and she manages the
Smithsonian's cultural rescue initiative
her presentation is Smithsonian cultural
rescue initiative Corey
the green good afternoon everybody I'm
the post-lunch speaker but I'll try to
be quick and interesting and the big
green arrow does it just for those of
you who might not be familiar with the
Smithsonian created in 19 or 1846 sorry
much older than that for the increase in
diffusion of knowledge thanks to James
Smith sins bequest British citizen who'd
never been to America but gave us a lot
of money to start an institution of
learning and we have 19 museums 9
research centers and a zoo to take care
of and in order to do that work we have
a lot of cultural heritage professionals
as well as scientists and I feel really
lucky to be there because we have a lot
of professionals everything from
facilities experts safety experts
conservators we have several different
conservation centers at the Smithsonian
including our museum conservation
Institute out in Suitland Maryland we
have yes this is where the Ark of the
Covenant is stored if you've ever
watched the Indiana Jones films just
kidding out at the Museum Support Center
in suitland so we're very lucky to have
people working on things like
volcanology and earthquake science and
the global climate change anything you
would want to find out about you can
find someone who's involved in that and
so that's why we have thought about this
initiative to serve as a
cross-disciplinary initiative across the
Smithsonian bringing together the best
of what we have available in recognition
resilience response and research for the
Smithsonian and for many many partners
that we've been working with over the
years and to include Yale University how
did the Smithsonian get involved in this
well of course we take care of America's
collections at the Smithsonian but we
first became very engaged in this in
about 2010 with the haiti earthquake and
and some of you may know that hate of
the Smithsonian has a folklife festival
on the mall every year it's a very large
celebration of both of international
cultural heritage as well as America's
cultural heritage and in 2004 this was
celebrated with the minister ministry of
culture of haiti and so when the
earthquake happened in 2010 many of our
colleagues who had served as fellows
during that time eventually rose to
positions of prominence within the
Haitian government and the Ministry of
Culture or were it housed at museums or
other cultural institutions and asked
for assistance and so this is how I
first met some of the colleagues working
on that initiative I was at the time the
president of the US Committee of the
Blue Shield and we partnered with the
American Institute for conservation and
their cultural emergency response teams
and many other organizations and
institutions including the International
Center for the preservation of cultural
heritage in Rome who will also hear from
today to help with that immediate
response and training for our colleagues
over 18-month project we worked with
many partners UNESCO you can see here we
worked with some of the Japanese blue
helmets to help us salvage collections
from the rubble this was at the center
for Haitian art and we trained more than
100 Haitian colleagues to be able to
respond and salvage and preserve and
also training for recovery operations
and post disaster recovery operations
over this 18-month project and we had
many conservators and staff deployed to
Haiti from the Smithsonian all of this
culminating and a large grant that we
received from the Ben Stiller Foundation
and working with our Haitian colleagues
in port-au-prince and the US Embassy in
Haiti to develop a Conservation training
center at Castilla University last year
so what else happened after that so that
was kind of the initial push and it was
a big push we got money from
USAID we worked with the President's
Committee on the arts and the humanities
worked with US Department of State as I
said and so we had a mix of
public-private partnerships to fund that
project in 2012 the Smithsonian became
even more engaged in the domestic
response for cultural heritage after
Hurricane sandy Smithsonian is part of
the Heritage emergency national task
force for domestic response for heritage
which is a group of about 40
public-private partnerships including
the interagency and now the Smithsonian
is the co-chair of the task force with
FEMA and we're working on a variety of
projects but we developed a cultural
crisis Recovery Center in New York City
after the hurricane sandy and worked
with a number of institutions on Salvage
of materials who see Carol gruesome from
our museum conservation Institute
working with colleagues from the Martha
Graham Dance Company so that it seemed
like after I came to the Smithsonian in
2012 that disasters seemed to become
more prevalent around the world after
the Arab Spring we saw the destruction
of cultural heritage and Molly we heard
about that from our colleagues and we
were asked we knew that there was a lot
of distress about the built heritage and
about the manuscripts collections in
Mali but we were asked to work
specifically with the museums and we
worked with a number of partners UNESCO
and the international council of museums
on this West African museum training
workshop that we held in 2014 there's
been a lot of discussion today about
Syria and Iraq so I'll briefly cover how
the Smithsonian is engaged in this with
a number of partners that you see here
and the main partners on the
safeguarding the heritage of Syria and
Iraq project are the Smithsonian and the
penn museum and cultural heritage center
but you see there have been a number of
partners along the way and with a mix of
public and private funding we did some
training in gaziantep turkey for
colleagues working in opposition
controlled parts of Syria and provided
them with information about him
emergency response and recovery salvage
rehousing of collections that have been
damaged in the conflict at this time the
primary damage to collections have been
caused by conflict between the warring
factions rather than Isis but that's
been a growing concern protecting
heritage collections from deliberate as
well as inadvertent damage to heritage
in the conflict our colleagues pointed
out that the thing that they most wanted
to do was to protect this particular
mosaics Museum enid lib province we
provided the training the materials
Botham tools all working with colleagues
at the Department of State to ensure the
best practices on this effort and as far
as transferring funds and that sort of
thing and they were able to protect that
but unfortunately last year that same
museum the Mara museum was bombed by two
very large barrel bombs and even though
the superstructure of this caravanserai
which is a historic building in and of
itself were severely damaged the facing
system and sandbagging actually
protected the mosaics and that has been
restored now more sandbags added to
preserve it one of the other parts of
the level the other part of the Syrian
Iraq project is the Iraq portion and
we're working with the Iraqi Institute
for the conservation of Antiquities and
heritage also along with the University
of Delaware and this is a State
Department funded project for the
Conservation Center in Erbil we've done
a lot of emergency training there but
they also trained in basic conservation
methods trying to create the next
generation of conservation colleagues in
Iraq after the Nepal earthquake in an
unprecedented collaboration with I komme
aus ich ROM icon the Smithsonian and the
Department of Antiquities in heritage
and Nepal we were able to do a quick
assessment and training first aid for
cultural heritage in Nepal after the
earthquake last year
working with a group of about 20
participants from museums across the
Katmandu Valley they worked together
with the Nepal military to provide some
salvage operations and then to go back
and train the trainers in their own
Museum and I would would be remiss if I
didn't mention my colleagues a part of
tendon from ekrim and rohit ji gasps ooh
from icomos and we worked really closely
together to provide to training courses
one for museum colleagues and one for
colleagues working on built heritage we
also felt it was necessary to train the
military which is kind of a expertise of
mine and help them to understand better
how to work with their colleagues in the
museum's on the ground we also train
civilians and other civilians and this
is the first aid for cultural heritage
in crisis partnership that we do this
between the Smithsonian and II kromm and
this was our class last year in the
Netherlands and this will be hosted this
year at the Smithsonian in the month of
june as part of that globe i showed you
we also do research there's been a lot
of discussion today also about okay i
have to finish up about documenting
sites we also have a documentation
project between the American Association
for the Advancement of science the
Smithsonian and the University of
Pennsylvania and we do it we're doing a
little bit different project though from
the National Science Foundation we have
a grant to record coordinates not it's
not just to document illicit traffic and
damage the ideas that we're creating a
data set about the destruction of
cultural heritage that will be a
scientific data set that people can use
to analyze damage to heritage and other
conflicts as well so it's more of a
larger scientific research project and
then you know we're always trying to
raise awareness we had a the death of
history exhibition for the US Senate
last fall to talk about raise awareness
with them about the damage to heritage
in Syria in Iraq and then as I mentioned
military training is kind of a specialty
and we do this in conjunction and
partnership with the US Committee of the
Blue Shield to teach our own US military
how
to recognize and respect cultural
heritage so that's all I have for you
right now thanks very much